tion de cas laurent bonsoir merci d'être
venu bon quelques mois déjà sur votre
réélection satisfaits et heureux ce soir
oui soulagé évidemment c'est votre style
cette réélection d'autant qu'elle a été
obtenue avec un nombre de voix supérieur
à ce que laissait penser la désignation
des des électeurs au mois de juin
donc c'est le signe que des électeurs de
gauche au delà que de ceux qui qui
devait normalement voté pour nous ont
voulu que je sois réélu et au delà je
crois que ça s'est passé dans d'autres
départements voulait en fait la présence
d'un groupe communiste républicain et
citoyen et s'asseoir vous avez les dix
sénateurs nécessaire la constitution
d'un groupe parlementaire ici au sénat
oui oui c'est certain il y aura group
est fait oui c'est sûr qu'il y aura un
groupe communiste républicain et citoyen
de 2,13 peut-être un peu plus au sénat
je pense que c'est très intéressant qui
mathématiquement ça n'était pas acquis
donc il s'est passé quelque chose parmi
notamment les électeurs de gauche de
cette élection qui ont souhaité je lis
bien l'entrée de notre groupe et je
pense que nous serons le coeur de
l'opposition à emmanuel macron dans le
dans le sénat est dans l'opposition
c'est peut-être vous savez que la france
insoumise avait décidé de ne pas
de ne pas présenter de candidats aux
élections sénatoriales donc la france
insoumise n'était pas présente dans
cette élection reste présente à
l'assemblée est dans la rue elle reste
alors en raison non mais là vous m'avez
beaucoup d'autres choses j'ai aucun
problème
combien au sénat le choeur de
l'opposition à la politique d' emmanuel
macron sera conduite par le groupe
communiste républicain et citoyen